hi hi how's it going good nice an actual
like that I know convenient yeah so this
is an interesting one because you guys
are telling the Rob Ford story but
you're obviously fixing some of it
so was there concerned that you're still
gonna be telling an authentic story with
this because you know there's gonna be
eyeballs watching this being like you
can get that right like you were you
worried about still telling an authentic
story no I think the I think the story
is very factual the characters are
fictional if that makes any sense so my
character for example and Nina's
character are based on loosely based
loosely based on a group of assistants
special assistants that Rob Ford had
behind them and he went through quite a
few during his reign in Toronto so when
people go watch the film I think they'll
remember the events but just keep in
mind that the characters are fictional
they are not real right now in terms of
reaction to this obviously whatever
you're telling a real-life story there's
real people that knew this story are
going to be paying attention to it they
have the Premier of Ontario Doug Ford
his brother is like are you curious to
see his reaction to this movie do you
want to hear his reaction to the movie
that's an interesting question
sure I mean I think that's the thing
about art is everybody can formulate
throw an opinion there's no right or
wrong art is subjective I think we
forget about that all the time and
because everyone can write their
opinions on Twitter it somehow makes it
seem like it's factual artists
subjective so anyone's welcome to come
watch and and voice their opinion
respectfully now I thought with both
your characters it's really a lot about
morals versus ambition like how you find
that balance yeah I don't think in
Hollywood I mean you ever have to deal
with a choice between worlds and
ambition
but Western element you could relate to
your characters in that sense with your
careers yes and I mean I think that all
the characters in this film are just
fighting to survive whether it's for
themselves their own ambitions or their
families whether it's your character who
is an immigrant and like we all have
different motivations behind why we do
certain things but but yeah it's weird
because like you you want to keep your
job and make money and or keep it have a
career but you have but sometimes you're
stuck between a rock and a hard place
and in order to do the right thing you
have to lose the right opportunity and
that is hard for some people
my character ends up making the moral
choice in the end other characters don't
but yeah I think we I think it's such a
universal trait I think you know
everyone everyone goes through that yeah
and were you you were based on trying to
win Rob Ford was married I was going to
Ryerson so I was very close to the whole
situation I was living downtown yeah
absolutely you're in LA when were your
thoughts when Rob Ford wasn't power like
really following it that much I mean you
couldn't really avoid it sure the
late-night talk shows were all
highlighting this Canadian politician
who was falling out of line with the
stereotype of being like a politically
correct polite Canadian yeah what's
happening yeah Canada's going to ride
saying weird things but yeah I think but
at the time everyone was sort of like
thought it was amusing they thought it
was charismatic and funny and it didn't
really affect everyone down south rob
was a very polarizing person yeah and
even in the city right he was very
polarizing it's
kind of like what's happening with Trump
you know a lot of people that I meet are
not fans of Trump but he got elected so
there's a lot of people who do like him
and a lot of people who are fans of him
Rob Ford was like that I feel like in in
this city and you guys said this like
2018 right yeah yes it was like last
fall you said you hadn't gotten any
audition since Aladdin right we talked
about on a show the amount of attention
that got wasn't like one that he got an
audition since then
yes okay good yes really surprised that
what a huge reaction that got yes and no
it was a dead time in Hollywood it was
around Christmastime there was nothing
going on so I feel like it was a juicy
story for people to pick up on the story
through an important story but I think
to me what was strange was that people
acted like this was the first time they
were hearing something like this when
you know we've heard this over and over
again and in Hollywood you know it's
something that we need to keep talking
about african-americans have been
fighting for their rights in Hollywood
for a very very long time and other
groups have to now as well it's it's
that simple - is coming right I have no
idea
no one has formally talked to me about
that honestly most of the information I
hear about that
I honestly read for the first time with
everyone else